well if I were a smarter man I suppose
I'd review this movie right before class
came out and I saw them breakable again
I want to talk about unbreakable so
let's talk about unbreakable unbreakable
was written and directed by M night
Shyamalan it came out in the year 2000
when Shyamalan was on this crazy ride
this man was said to be the next
Spielberg something happened along the
way hopefully he's getting back on track
but personally I think unbreakable might
just be his masterpiece movie that was
truly ahead of his time so Bruce Willis
plays David Dunn he's a man who was in a
train wreck and he is the only survivor
of this train wreck in fact he's
remarkably unharmed he's in approached
by a man named Elijah price played by
samuel l.jackson who has osteogenesis
imperfecta it's a bone condition where
your bones are very brittle and they
break very easily he believes that if he
is on this end of the spectrum code
through then be a person on the other
end of the spectrum who does not break
who was very tough he believes David
Dunn is this person in fact he believes
David Dunn is a superhero or at least he
believes comic books are a
representation of the truth
exaggerations of the truth and so that's
the movie is Bruce Willis's character a
superhero is Elijah price gonna be like
the Alfred to the superhero this Bruce
Willis discovering how far this goes I
simply put this movie's remarkable it's
well directed yeah M night Shyamalan
movie was well directed folks it
happened all the time back then Bruce
Willis he's so somber in this movie his
marriage is down in the dumps he's
depressed it doesn't want to go to work
it's also represented the color and
contrast in the movie to a lot of blue a
lot of gray a lot of purple because Sam
Jackson knows how to dress but it is
touched on in the movie it's like if
you're this depressed and miserable
maybe you're not doing what you're
supposed to be doing samuel l.jackson
was also great the first real scene you
get of him is when this guy's buying
this art piece and by our piece I mean
comic book cover art page and he just
flips his [ __ ] on this guy because this
guy's buying it for his kid he's like
this is an art gallery my friend and
this is a piece of art it was really
funny because back in 2000 eccentric
adults buying a lot of expensive nerd
[ __ ] that was weird today it happens a
lot more but any time you can give me a
path of discovery based on entry because
like as Elijah price told David Dunn in
this movie is like if someone was like
you if they are unbreakable as I think
you are they probably wouldn't know it
is true you're like I guess they
wouldn't I mean I could be invincible
I've never broken a bone ever knock on
wood what sound effects we can make
anything happen
digital knock on wood account but it's
done in such a believable way but you
never feel like this guy is actually
invincible it's done in the spectrum of
believability early spectrum of
possibility he never feels like Superman
in fact I don't know the depth of how
invincible Bruce Willis actually is or
his character actually at Bruce Willis
we know he's invincible as hell he's
done that movie and still gets jobs
invincible in fact he is unbreakable
which makes you reflect what am I good
at what talents might I have that I
don't know I have because I've never
been in the position or situation to
find out I can do that maybe you can
sing maybe you can write maybe you are
great at drawing but you might not know
because you've never done it a try I
wish point the movie then does but I
really love it when a movie can do cause
self reflection it's not until a certain
point in the movie that you actually
stop and you're like this is a superhero
movie it's not executed that way in fact
the trailer you didn't know what this
movie was about all we knew was the guy
who wrote and directed The Sixth Sense
is making a movie where Bruce Willis
lives through a train crash what is it
is it a ghost movie is he dead again we
don't know I remember watching it with
my dad I rented the movie after it came
out over dad you got to save this movie
so we watched and at a point he goes
he's a [ __ ] superhero it's so great
seeing him reach that realization the
movie does a good job at you rooting for
everybody in this movie you're rooting
for Bruce Willis to find his place and
gain happiness and you're rooting for
Elijah price to be right about him funny
thing though when I was watching it this
time I was thinking I was like if this
is a world where this guy was like
hounding me thinking I was some sort of
superhero
he'd be remarkably annoying at any point
you have some guy you've never met you
have a meeting with once you're like
okay whatever bye he shows about your
work I think starts hounding your wife I
feel like there was fretting orders in
the mailman you're kind of weird just
really like what about Bob we're rooting
for Bob because it's what about Bob and
it's Bill Murray every love him he's
lovable but if we were in the position
of dr. Leo Marvin we would understand
this is also proof that samuel l.jackson
can play a more introverted reserved
intellectually soft-spoken or
inquisitive type of character he doesn't
always have to shout in fact there's a
bit of mace windu I see an elisha prize
in this movie Randy this was after the
Phantom Menace came out but although he
was more reserved than a samuel
l.jackson ish character usually is you
still always felt his passion that's the
important part never mistake energy with
passion they are not to say and this
sound
tract in this movie unbreakable theme is
one of those great themes of the 21st
century I can listen to that thing a
hundred times over the first note comes
on I recognize it immediately James
Newton Howard did such a good job in the
soundtrack of this movie such a somber
tone that also inspires hope it's a
hopeful and depressing tune I don't like
this movie really guys I don't want to
talk about this movie too much because
then the off-chance you haven't seen
unbreakable you totally should this
movie it was truly ahead of its time I
didn't recognize that until recently
until the recent comic book movies genre
boom that happened you make this movie
in the year 2000 it's a passion project
this is little thing that Shyamalan
wanted to do I suppose it would connect
with some moviegoers but not the
majority majority of people didn't watch
comic book movies when this movie came
out it's a very narrow market that we're
going for the movie after all is 18
years old
that means if someone was born when this
movie came out they are graduating high
school now I feel like unbreakable is
the inevitable end game the wrap around
for comic book movies and where they're
gonna go you already see certain Studios
try to do different things with comic
book movies at a point they're gonna be
like okay we've seen realistic before
you know Batman Begins there was a super
realistic ish take on Batman let's take
it to the next level make it almost look
like it's not a superhero movie at all
and you could be like yeah unbreakable
did that because it was ahead of its
time
I look back and I'm like that movie is
more relevant now than it was back then
it's so great when a movie you liked
back in the day has aged like a fine
wine I was so pleased watching
unbreakable again recently and have a
say unbreakable is awesome tacular
I would love to hear in the trailer for
glass audio of Elijah prices mom giving
her monologue about the soldier villain
and the arch villain I'm gonna break the
trailer for glass if it doesn't have it
but I think that would just be wonderful
alright guys so unbreakable have you
seen it what did you think about it has
your perception of unbreakable change
between when it came out and now
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]